- [Narrator] Budapest, Hungary,
is an architectural gem,
built from the union of three cities.
And nothing symbolizes this union better
than its one of a kind parliament
built to celebrate a millennia
of Hungary's existence.
(curious music)
Perched elegantly on the east
bank of the Danube river,
the Hungarian parliament
building is an example
of neo-Gothic architecture
with some renaissance
and baroque elements.
Commissioned in 1880,
it was finally completed 24 years later.
Its 314 feet tall and 880 feet long,
making it one of the
largest parliament buildings
in the world.
It's said that over a
thousand people were involved
in its construction,
during which 40 million bricks,
half a million precious stones,
and 88 pounds of gold were used.
The inside is home to
Hungary's National Assembly-
the legislative branch of the country.
The rest of the building's
10 courtyards and hundreds
of offices are linked through
a system of endless corridors
and a red carpet, which
is nearly two miles long.
One of the highlight's
is the nation's crown,
worn by about 50 rulers;
the first of which reigned
in the 12th century.
And like the treasures inside,
the building itself shines
like a jewel in this nation's skyline.